hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor
remember to look at the link in the
description below for a tiny url which
will take you to a collection of free
study notes
so these are pictures of all of the
final boards with all of the blanks
filled in
and all of the notes written on the
board you can get those for free by
clicking on that link
also remember to subscribe and hit the
bell icon for notifications so you can
get more free biology study videos today
we're going to be talking about acnes
now acnes
are survival structures
so they are structures that are made
for survival
specifically in
cyanobacteria in the ordered amounts to
colonies so this is not something that
like just any old bacterium can do it's
really the specific
group of cyanobacteria now you might be
hearing survival structures and thinking
hey this sounds like endospores and
you're right now acnes are not
endospores they're not um the same thing
endospores are those um survival
structures formed by gram-positive
bacteria
in the bacillus and clostridium genera
and i have a lot of different videos on
endospores like what endospores are the
sporulation process through which they
are formed the endospore stain
so that you can visualize them under a
microscope so if you're learning about
endospores make sure you check out those
videos and they should help you a lot
now let's get back to talking about
acnes their characteristics are going to
be similar to the characteristics of
endospores but not not exactly the same
so acnes they are enveloped
they are thick-walled and they are
non-modal so you're not going to see
little flagella popping out and these
acne swimming around no that doesn't
happen they don't they don't move
they're not mobile
so envelope thick walled and i've drawn
it here in blue this right here is the
acne so you can see there's the envelope
which gives it a very thick thick um
layer on on that belt on the outside
it's also quite resistant to certain
conditions it is resistant to cold
okay it's like cold conditions and it
can still survive and persist but
interestingly not hot
so it's good if the environment the
temperature is becoming
unfavorably cool but not very helpful if
the temperature is increasing
and getting hot it's also the acnes are
resistant
to desiccation
remember that desiccation is a fancy
word
for drying
so resistant to when things get very
very dry and there's not much water
available so when it's becoming
dehydrated
um another characteristic of acne is
that they are enlarged at least compared
to vegetative cells okay so over here in
green i've drawn the vegetative
cyanobacteria
you can see that they are a lot smaller
than this great big acne so the acne is
quite large compared to
like a normal kind of metabolically
active vegetated cyanobacterium
now when do the acnes develop well a
vegetative cell
can
develop into an acne when conditions
become unfavorable
so this might be triggered
by insufficient light
remember that
cyanobacteria
are photosynthetic
so so if there's insufficient light
to meet their energy requirements
these vegetative cells might be
triggered to develop into acne
insufficient nutrients
will
also
cause
this development into acne or
unfavorable
temperatures
[Music]
or unfavorable salinity basically if the
salt concentration is getting outside of
its preferred range
these are all things that basically are
unfavorable conditions that might
trigger
a vegetative cell
to turn into an acne
now when conditions become more
favorable the acne can germinate that
simply means returning to the vegetative
state
so to germinate would have the acne
developing back into a vegetative
cell
now i want you to make sure you realize
that acnes are not entirely dormant okay
now endospores basically are they're
basically dormant structures and a
holding pattern just waiting for
conditions to become more favorable
again
but with acnes there's still a low level
of activity going on inside so they're
still capable of low levels of
photosynthesis protein synthesis carbon
fixation some of these major metabolic
processes they can still do like a
little of okay
now let's kind of take a look
i know i've been referencing this
diagram a lot throughout remember the
green or the vegetative cyanobacteria
the blue
is the enlarged acne all of those little
circles inside represent the reserve
food materials
so those are held in reserve and and
acne is trying to basically stretch them
out so even though this low level of
some metabolic activity is happening
it's really trying to save those those
nutrient stores
for for sort of long term for survival
now i also want to draw your attention
to these cells drawn in purple these are
heterocysts
heterocysts are specialized nitrogen
fixing cells
now i have a full-length video on
heteroassists when i say full-length i
mean like you know still less than 20
minutes
um where you can check out what
heterocysts are what they do how they're
formed all the cool things about them so
check that out if you want to learn more
about heterocysts
now acne
usually develop
nearby
heterocysts
and this kind of makes sense to me
because heterocysts
they tend to form
during periods of nitrogen starvation
and they really double down on fixing
nitrogen and share it with the cells
around them so these heterocysts here
can fix nitrogen and share it with the
acne
when things are pretty unfavorable
otherwise
and so these are different ways you know
the heterocysts and the acnes are
different ways in which a group of
cyanobacteria can
basically
specialize and and
ensure their survival
when
things when conditions are not
maybe the best for them so remember to
get your free study uh study pdfs the
three notes by clicking the link in the
description below remember to subscribe
and thank you for watching biology
professor i will see you next time bye